[Music]
we've had a lot of credits and tears
over the last few weeks
because they have been locked up they've
been so happy to be out
it doesn't matter how much donald trump
protests if he loses the election
come january 20th he's done he's gone
i think rick would be quite proud of me
i think you say
go on lad it may have not been much
screen time but i walked through the
forest of dean bits of north wales
and half of yorkshire
[Music]
all week we've been speaking to people
across greater manchester
about living under new coronavirus
measures in wigan i spoke
with bev collier nelson who runs the
soft play centre one of the many venues
forced to close
under the new tier 3 restrictions she
says not only is she worried about her
business
but about the families that go there
we've done everything that's been asked
of us we had a huge
list of guidelines that we had to put in
place before we opened
we made sure that we covered every
single one to make sure it's safe
and at the moment i'm i'm at a loss as
to where we can turn because we've done
everything that's been asked of us
we've got all our guidelines in place
and parents and children seem happy
it's not just about running around
there's a lot of emotional
well-being that goes on in the play
centre and i know we've had a lot of
credits and tears over the last few
weeks
because they have been locked up they've
been so happy to be out
what do i say to them when they're
getting in touch with me asking when
when can we be open it's just so sad
and for you when you saw that news
come in that you would be going into
these tier three restrictions
how did it make you personally feel
seeing this build this business that
you've built up and this kind of
community that you've created
not wanting to get too upset at the end
of the day i am a mum of three children
myself
and as much as this is a financial
situation and
we've got to keep a financial head on
here i
i have a lot of permits who i'm very
very close to now and i just feel for
them
massively i struggle when i'm at home so
i can understand we've got new parents
of babies that have been born in
lockdown and where they're first place
they've trusted to come
and now that rug's been pulled from
under them as well where are they going
to go what are they going to turn to
they're keeping gyms open for adults
mental health
i think that play centers are you know
just as important for children and
adults
[Music]
the main story on the programme for you
today is what's been happening
in greater manchester over the last few
days we heard from andy burnham just
yesterday he said he was still hopeful
that there would be a deal
with the government and that he was
writing to the prime minister yesterday
morning and then he found out
live on air while he was holding a news
conference
that actually the deal wasn't going to
happen well obviously it was a great
shame that we weren't able to reach
agreement with greater manchester we
tried extremely hard i had conversations
as did the prime minister's
advisers ed lister and the prime
minister himself spoke to
the mayor andy burnham yesterday but the
public health situation in greater
manchester was deteriorating
the evidence that we were receiving
about the capacity of
some of the hospitals in greater
manchester the number of cases the fact
it was rising up
uh the age brackets to those people who
were in greater danger
of ill health it's gone down it uh know
what
the the number of cases rising in some
parts of greater manchester it's
it seems there's some evidence of it um
plateauing in the center
of manchester perhaps linked to
universities but they're very clear
publicly as well the very clear public
health advice
can i just finish answering the question
but you're saying it's going up and i'm
saying
blatantly it isn't because i'm not i'm
not sure what statistics you're actually
looking at there because the
the very clear public health advice that
i received
from the nhs from nhs england and the
chief medical officer
was that this was a serious and
deteriorating situation in greater
manchester
and that we needed to act okay um as i
said the figures from manchester the
city of manchester have gone
down something the prime minister didn't
mention in his briefing yesterday was
about gyms
in greater manchester are they allowed
to stay open or not
um i think that gyms are being asked to
close
um but you'll have to look on gov.uk
when
or we can revert to you when the
regulations are published
but we've adopted the same model as
lancashire
is having as the nearest neighbor of
greater manchester
okay interesting that we don't know the
answer to that
let's send where we started with andy
burnham should we i mean it's a win-win
for him really isn't he's come across as
a working-class hero and all of those
red wall um constituencies that you
wanted that you won over
at the last election are going to be
looking at the westminster elite and
thinking
he maybe will vote labour at the next
election
well i'm not interested in showboating
or indeed in personalities
i'm interested in public health we
discussed with leaders in greater
manchester
so for 10 or 11 days how we could take
action
against a very serious public health
crisis
in the city region but by saying that
forgive me mr jerry but by saying that
you're suggesting that he is not
interested
in in the health of you can you ask me a
question about whether this will lead to
how people vote in a future election i
say that is not in
my thoughts what i want to do is take
decisive action now to keep people safe
i also want to ensure that we protect
their livelihoods by putting in place
the right financial package
we will do that for greater manchester
people at home should know
that regardless of personalities we will
provide the support that they deserve
they were told to get off the streets
they were told to stay at home
by the authorities
[Applause]
but the anger and frustration felt by
many in nigeria
has spilled into the city of lagos
it's been building over the course of
the past two weeks
a protest against an unpopular police
unit
has turned into something else a
challenge to the government's ability to
rule this is the most important moment
in nigeria's history the most
by far important moment of nigeria's
history
that's what we're witnessing right now
you know because
if nothing changes after this if
if this doesn't work then
you know it's over
you know it's over what do you mean by
that
it's over i mean
look at what's going on now
the youth have come together
like something
something on unexplainable something
that no one man could have possibly
organized or
or led yeah
the youth of the who of the largest
black nation in the world
came together and decided enough is
enough
and this this was triggered by police
brutality
right it's not like it was triggered by
all the other things that it should have
been triggered by
all these years yeah it was triggered by
this police brutality that has been
happening forever
were you surprised at what young people
in nigeria managed to do with those
protests
because you have been critical of the
youth in nigeria
you have said they deserve the leaders
they get because they
have been generally apathetic yeah and i
take those words back
now they made they made me eat those
words didn't they
you know because now yeah they
they they made something that i've only
seen in
in my in my wildest dreams
yeah a reality you know
i didn't even i never thought that
anything like this could ever happen
not even not in my lifetime not when i'm
dead
do you understand but now i feel so
blessed
and privileged to witness this day and
this age this liberation generation
and to be part of it is i feel like it's
the biggest achievement
it's the biggest thing my life like i've
ever seen in my life and i've never been
a part of it
it's black poetry day which honors past
and present
black poets the day also commemorates
the birth of the first published black
poet in the united states jupiter
hammond
was born in long island new york on
october 17
17 11. i think any black poet that lends
an authentic voice to the black
experience
is unbelievably important from the nikki
giovanni's to the more modern poets like
george the poet for example
um i think in all of this in the essence
of balance where perhaps one narrative
of black people is
more prevalent and sometimes detrimental
to the perception of blackness
it's very important to tell the lived
experience of black people
to illuminate black voices to humanize
black voices
in a world where sometimes the notion of
blackness is
quite negative the black lives matter
has been such a memorable part of 2020
one of the really positive parts i
suppose you could say
that have come out of all of the
difficulties of this year how much extra
energy and impetus do you think it has
given to this year's
black poetry day over the past few
months we've kind of seen a physical
show
of where we are as a society of racism
so
i think having these spaces and carving
out time to celebrate to understand to
look at the statistics to look at the
history
to study the stories to study the people
to study the greats
i think carving out time to do that is
in 2020 has become that much more
important because it's right in our face
now i suppose whatever your race
whatever your creed or color
poetry is very often perceived isn't it
as a sort of an elite form
of literature what got you into it what
wetted your appetite
um so i always make up answers to this
when someone asks me because i can't
completely remember but i do remember
really enjoying hip hop and i loved the
idea that you could tell
an entire story and i could meet
someone's mom their dad their
relationship
in perhaps four bars or eight bars or 32
bars or a chorus
i love the fact that you could hear a
line that would seem to speak directly
to your heart
and suddenly you felt seen you felt less
alone you might have felt empowered or
inspired
and i've always just seen that as so
powerful so i think
when i was 14 15 with a lot less finesse
and
perhaps no charm to how i would perform
i just picked up a pen and i started
trying to do that for myself and for
other people and
it just it just didn't stop so for you
what are the themes then that come out
in your poetry what do you write about
um so my collection is called somebody
give this heart a pen and i think
that generally is my focus it's the idea
that
we all have our stories whether it's a
story on love or loss
on puberty on identity on confidence how
we struggle with confidence
on race on school on on whatever it
might be we all have these stories and
i think in telling these stories in
giving our heart a pen
we create an honest history and in doing
that we introduce empathy into each
other as people and i think
at a time like now especially 2020 what
we need is more empathy what we need is
understanding what we need is
to be more forgiving as a society
[Music]
from 2009 to and michael steele was the
chair of the republican
national committee running the national
party he's always voted republican but
not this time
this election he's calling on voters to
elect the democratic nominee joe biden
he spoke to skies damn at manhattan we
should not be fighting over being
americans we should not be fighting over
uh who we are as citizens and what our
responsibility
uh to each other is but more importantly
what is the responsibility of
the president to the citizens of this
country so for me it was character
it was a matter of of understanding and
appreciating
someone like joe biden who shows his
empathy
who cares about um the the well-being of
of his fellow americans does not mock
them does not make fun of them
doesn't disparage women uh doesn't uh
you know uh ignore the concerns of
minorities
um so those things outweigh the the
policy differences
and the political uh dynamics um
it's about the country and it's about uh
you know what it means to be an american
but you know what this means if you get
your way if you get your wish
the republican party is smashed
it has to rebuild from the ground up but
you think that's a price worth paying
the the republican party is smashed
anyway it was already damaged i i
recognized that when i was national
chairman
i had to contend with that emerging
frustration known as the tea party
which over time changed and morphed and
became
you know the freedom caucus inside the
house you know that took down
two republican house house speakers um
and now
has emerged on the other side as
this trumpism this sort of white
populism
white nationalistic populism uh that is
corrosive
so the party has um a lot of
cleaning out to do and it has been long
um in trying to get that done and i
think now
where we are you're going to see that
accelerated because the country's
changing
um the united states is no longer stuck
in the 1950s and the 1960s
it is more dynamic it is more diverse
and the party needs to speak to that and
you don't speak to minorities in the
country
when you when they say black lives
matter and your response is
all lives matter or you say with respect
to white nationalism well they're fine
people on both sides
so you have to understand where the
country is and move into that space
well let me ask you about the the next
few weeks potentially and put a scenario
to you
president trump loses narrowly and
uh we know the narrative he's been
preparing already
that he's been cheated out of it that he
disputes some of the results in some of
those key states
he refuses to concede he refuses to
leave the white house would you be
amongst those senior republicans who
would go into the white house and say
sir
you have got to go for the sake of the
constitution for the sake
of american democracy at the end of the
day
it doesn't matter how much donald trump
protests if he loses the election
come january 20th he's done he's gone um
president biden will have the marshals
and the secret service move him out if
he refuses to leave
i doubt that will happen if he doesn't
want to cooperate with the transition
that's his prerogative there's no
statutory or constitutional requirement
that he cooperates with the incoming
administration
but at the end of the day when the
election is said and done and been
certified and the electoral college
cast his votes the president's term is
over
a new president will assume the the
leadership of the country
and america will can move forward and
continue to build from there
after months of delays due to the
coronavirus crisis sky cinema's
adaptation of the classic novel the
secret garden
has just been released the movie tells
the story of a young girl sent to live
with her uncle
who discovers a magical garden in his
estate i spoke to cast members colin
firth and dixie edgerix to find out how
they brought this enchanting tale to
life
and what if i were to tell you she
discovered something magical
something secret
it looks absolutely idyllic the sets i
mean particularly for you dixie colin
you're stuck inside for the vast
majority of the movie but
was it as nice as that running around in
the woods or if i got a very uh naive
view of filmmaking
no it was i i really loved it you know
and
um like you know obviously a lot of the
time when you're filming you're in a
studio or
you know just inside which is all well
and good but
i did just really love being outside and
we got to go to all these amazing
british gardens
and yeah i loved it and i i was kind of
shocked because you know
i had no idea that there was such um
diversity
in the plants and stuff that we have in
the uk but
we did um and yeah i i really loved it
i just add to that by the way one of the
purposes of filmmaking
is all too often it looks as if you're
in a beautiful place and in fact
not for me it was sort of the reverse
because the only bit where i'm outside
really is towards the end when i go off
looking for colin
and um it may have not been much screen
time but i walked through the forest of
dean bits of north wales and
half of yorkshire in order to complete
that little walk
uh so i did get to see quite a lot of it
and it was gorgeous
see that is the that is the magic of
filmmaking
but so often we just hear of you being
stuck on a cold set so it's nice that
you actually got to be uh properly
outside all the time
and that kind of being outside all the
time it feels quite old-fashioned now
doesn't it you know we're
stuck in this world of social media in
screens and everything else
do you think colin that that makes this
film sort of even more
escapism from the now where we're even
more in front of screens and things like
that than we
sort of normally would be if you'd asked
me that question a year ago i'd have
said yes certainly
um but i think you know it's a bit too
soon to judge the effect that
kovid and lockdowns has been having on
us all
but it does strike me i certainly have
seen this in people close to me that
those
those who have been stuck in front of
screens
uh have had enough of that you know
because that's all we've had
and i think there's a real longing now
to make to get out there and whether
it's
to connect with nature or each other i
think
maybe there's a bit of a waking up that
says you know screens don't really do it
um so perhaps perhaps it's going to have
a different
resonance now than it might have done a
year ago yeah absolutely
um and of course you reunite with julie
walters in this
uh she said that perhaps uh she might
not do another film unless it's mamma
mia three is that a project you'd like
to uh
you'd be keen for as well we can always
dream
um i you know i the likelihood of that i
can't i can't comment on
um you know i i suppose
i suppose there are more songs or why
not use
just use them all again um but i'm sure
you won't find anybody that wouldn't be
keen to show up
now i think we're all in the mood for a
story that's going to
lift our spirits well 10 year old max
woozy
could be about to do just that he's been
camping out in his garden for more than
200
days and he's doing it to raise money
for a local hospice he's sleeping in a
tent
left to him by a neighbor who was looked
after at the hospice in his
final days and it may be getting cold
outside but max who's raised
around 75 000 pounds so far isn't
planning to come back inside the house
until he spent a full year in his
garden it all started because of our
friends rick and c
unfortunately passed away but rick was
amazing man
he loved the outdoors and then
i'm you saw him inside was um
when there was rugby on and he left max
kent he wanted him to have it and made
him promise to have an adventure in it
so rick said
have an adventure in my tent before he
sadly died
uh you put the tent up in the garden and
we were you intending to spend all this
time in it or was it just gonna be one
or two nights
um is that like i did
i think about 10 nights and said
i want to do 50 then i say to my friends
look i've done 50 nights
it's an amazing thing and then i wanted
to go to 100
then i wanted to go to 200 now i want to
do a year
you've raised a huge amount of money
just tell me what the total is at the
moment
um including gifted it's something
around like
96 000 pounds including gifted 96
000 pounds well stephen uh who is the
chief executive
of the uh hospice i mean that's going to
go a long way isn't it that sort of
money
uh a huge way um for us you know max is
an absolute beacon of support for our
care and
in real terms that will cover two nurses
for an entire year
so max is genuinely making a huge impact
on people's lives just when they need
our care
max what do you think rick would say
about all of this he said have an
adventure
you're certainly having one i think
rick would be quite proud of me i think
you say go on lad
i think i think if he was still alive
now
i think he'd be over there in the tent
next to me
[Music]